nadège bonjour alors dites nous tout est
ce que l'on va pouvoir danser cet été
c'est la question qui est sur toutes les
lèvres des organisateurs de festivals
roselyne bachelot la ministre de la
culture annonce des expérimentations
pour permettre la reprise hypothétique
du spectacle vivant après l'espagne
l'allemagne et bientôt le royaume uni et
les pays bas la france devrait organiser
les premiers concerts tests sous
contrôle scientifique
objectif permettre de mesurer le taux de
transmission du virus entre les
spectateurs soumis à un protocole et à
partir de là autoriser ou non la tenue
des concerts et des festivals cet été
je suis très optimiste pour les
festivals et spectacles à 6 pour les
spectacles de boue c'est plus compliqué
il y aura deux concerts test acier avec
possibilité de se lever au dôme de
marseille sous réserve d'une situation
sanitaire catastrophique
il pourrait avoir lieu dans la deuxième
quinzaine de mars
nous voulons également organisé un
concert debout à l'accord arena de paris
en avril alors la belge des concerts
organisés en collaboration avec
l'institut national de la santé et de la
recherche médicale comment ça va se
passer très concrètement absolument
alors dans les grandes lignes 2000
personnes seront sélectionnées avec un
premier groupe de 1000 personnes
masquées un premier concert une semaine
plus tard on inverse les groupes l'un
assistent aux concerts l'autre pas tous
les participants sont testés la veille
sept jours et 14 jours après le concert
alors pour se mettre dans des situations
de brassage roselyne bachelot la
ministre de la culture explique que les
entrants seront testés mais les
personnes positives ne seront pas
filtrer l'ensemble des participants sera
masqué aura à sa disposition du gel
hydroalcoolique autantde annonce qui
pourrait donc faire évoluer la situation
du monde culturel bloqué depuis
maintenant bientôt un an
merci beaucoup nadège pour ces
précisions on va bien entendu suivre
cette réunion aujourd'hui sur rt france